sue Aikens has spent the past four
months in Fairbanks recovering from
surgery as kavik River Camp sole
proprietor her absence is left this site
uninhabited and unprotected I have to
visually check everything behind any
corner any trailer it's the things you
don't see that bite you in the ass I got
injured in the winter and it was very
cold very snowy in winter
I've been town through the flooding for
months of thought out it has gone
through the awakening of the Bears
there's 83 Bears tag within so many
miles of camp that can walk through I
can't go in unarmed in case something
decides to take me out of the equation
you got a scratch here that's been torn
how do you know it's new well it's a
different color it's bright yellow all
the other wood is weathered this is
yellowish can't say if it's a bear can't
say what it is it's just that
I don't see where the building isn't is
has been the integrity has not been
compromised on the building but you can
see something pushed okay I don't see
any breaks in the material I'm gonna go
on the Twinkie
dark in here
the door back here is still shut so
that's good as I'm looking for did
something open a door is there a problem
I don't care if the Bears come scratch
scratch scratch I care about open open
open
so everything's looking pretty good and
silly as it seems this right here coffee
grounds that I spread everywhere what it
does it a bears nose is so sensitive
that mild acidic scent is just like an
outhouse they don't like it it is a
miracle that I was able to be gone and
no bears came in they scratched and they
didn't destroy it that is it's pretty
amazing I feel proud of myself for that
one lucky [ __ ] in camp nothing ate it
but I got a lot of clean up to do